hey guys do you know how to color match
your clothes if you don't then you need
to know that putting on the wrong color
combinations can really mess up your
whole look
now there's 12 basic color combinations
on the color wheel now that's not a lot
but the problem is is that you can
combine them in over 60 different ways
now that's a lot of colors to remember
so which of them match and which don't
match how do you know you see it gets
confusing so in this video I'm gonna
give you the best color matching trick
that's gonna help you out let's get to
it I have a dream
[Music]
made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong now just very quick if your first
time here on my channel I'm Daniel and
welcome to D LM model lifestyle
subscribe and also click that
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos now let me tell you
the secret of color matching neutral
colors won't clash with each other
that's very important because it means
that you can match them with any color
you want and it's gonna look great so
what are the neutral colors well they
are black white and grey but in the
fashion world Navy and brown can also be
considered as neutral colors why well
simply for the fact that they work so
well with many other colors out there
now when I say brown it includes beige
khaki
camel and etc it's not just light brown
or dark brown and I remember instead of
worrying all the time of which colors to
match together all you gotta do is wear
one color in your outfit and the rest
keep the colors neutral like this for
example
[Music]
now just a bonus tip you can also add
another color but only if it's in the
same color family like this for example
now remember you don't need to look like
a rainbow whenever you leave the house
all you gotta do is just wear one color
with your neutral colors and it is
enough to look sharp and stylish now if
you want to see some other videos on
style Fitness grooming check out some of
these videos and I'll see you in the
next video
cheers guys
[Music]